Good morning. Thanks for coming.
I'm here to introduce, uh,
Amanda gefter and her book
trespassing on Einstein's lawn.
And I came to this book through a
confluence of several factors. My,
my late father was a physicist and had
the opportunity to exchange a few letters
with Einstein himself and,
uh,
always had them locked away
in the safe deposit box.
It was always a special family
thing. And, um, separately,
he and my mother used to go to a,
a particular Chinese restaurant
in Philadelphia all the
time. And the young son,
five year old son of the owners would
always hang around and, you know,
being playful. But he also liked
math a lot. And my dad, uh, um,
started tutoring him in math young man,
grew up, went to Wharton and is now, uh,
at Khosla partners of venture capitalist
out in, uh, out in silicon valley.
So my dad helped, helped spawn
a silicon valley hot shot. Um,
so when I heard of Amanda's book
and that it involved Einstein,
physics, father's restaurant,
Chinese restaurants,
and Philadelphia where,
where I'm from,
I realized this was the book I had
to read. So, uh, without further ado,
Amanda gefter.
Okay.
So first I just want to thank Google
so much for hosting me here today.
It's a real privilege to be here in this
building and to get to talk to all of
you.
So
when I was 15 years old,
my father took me out to dinner at our
favorite Chinese restaurant and asked me
how I would define nothing.
And this was an odd dinner table question,
but not entirely out of
character for my father,
who was the sort of Zen Guru,
like former hippy turned radiologist.
And so I said I would define nothing as
the absence of something or the absence
of everything. And really this is how
everyone defines nothing as avoid.
But my father had a different idea. He
had been thinking about this for a while.
He told me,
and the other day he had had an epiphany.
He was at the mechanics waiting
for his car to be fixed.
And it dawned on him that you could
define nothing as an infinite,
unbounded homogeneous state.
So a state of utter sameness that
extends without bound forever.
And this wasn't a semantic trick and
an infinite unbounded homogeneous state
would literally be indistinguishable
from a void. It's nothing.
But my father thought it was an
interesting definition because it defined
nothing. Not In terms of what it
isn't, but in terms of what it is.
And so he explained all this to me over
a plate of cashew chicken and then he
asked me,
do you think this could help
explain how the universe began?
Now you have to bear mine.
I'm his teenage daughter.
I was not exactly the
most well behaved kid.
I would not be described as studious.
I was failing math class.
I was not even taking physics class.
I had opted for meteorology because
that was what my high school offered in
place of physics for the underachievers.
And here are my father is asking
me how the universe began.
And he just sort of shrugged like it
was a normal thing to do and said,
I think we should figure it out.
And so that is how at 15 years old,
I found myself on a mission to figure
out the origin of the universe.
So my father and I started
teaching ourselves physics. Um,
we stayed up late every night.
We started amassing a crazy
collection of physics books,
reading everything we could get our hands
on and talking about all these ideas
until my mother would
yell at us to go to bed.
Because if you want to understand this,
something that came from nothing
when the universe was born,
you have to look at
both sides of the coin.
So my father had already thought long and
hard about the nothing part and now we
needed to understand the something
and that's what physics is.
Which incidentally,
before I started the
secret project with my dad,
I had no idea what physics was.
I didn't take physics class because I
thought that physics was like a set of
rules and numbers for describing
how like levers and police work.
And now I know that physics is about
uncovering the reality behind the
appearances.
It's about glimpsing this deep and
hidden architecture of existence itself.
It's about embracing the fact that the
world is not what it seems and that
everything is stranger and simpler than
we can imagine. And yet comprehensible.
And I think if I had
known that from the start,
I wouldn't have taken meteorology.
But eventually I graduated high school
and I moved to New York City for college.
And then when I finished college,
I did what any physics loving
amateur reality hunter would do.
And I took a job at a bridal magazine.
So I was working as an assistant,
that Manhattan bride and
I was there in the office,
which was really just the one bedroom
apartment of a guy named Rick.
When I read an article in the New York
Times announcing this huge physics
conference that was going to
be happening in Princeton,
New Jersey called science
and ultimate reality,
and all of the world's leading physicists
were going to gather there to talk
about their most cutting edge ideas.
So I'm reading this article and a
light bulb goes off over my head.
I wait until Rick leaves for lunch
and then I pick up the phone,
I call the people in charge of
publicity for the conference.
And in the most professional
voice that I can muster,
I lie and say that I am a journalist.
And then I'm calling from Manhattan
magazine because that sounded better.
And then I wanted to come cover the event.
Oh,
of course we would love you to
come. They said, great. I said,
put me down on plus one.
Now, in that moment,
I had no idea how that one little lie
would forever alter the course of my life,
but I called my dad and I said, pack
your bags. We're going to Princeton.
So my dad and I show up in Princeton
and we crashed this physics conference
posing as journalists.
You know,
we found our press badges at the press
table mindset in Manhattan magazine.
I had a blank for my plus one and we put
them around our necks and just wandered
amongst our heroes, like two idiot
Deere cotton genius headlights.
We got to listen to these
physicists lecture about
their most recent ideas about
the nature of reality.
And then as if that wasn't good enough,
we got to go into this magical little
room that they call the press room where
you sit down and they deliver to
you one by one, each physicist,
so you can ask them questions.
It was the most amazing
experience of my entire life.
And when the conference let out my father
and I had just sort of like wandered
through the town of Princeton in a daze,
talking about everything we had just
heard and eventually we found ourselves on
Mercer Street,
which is the street where Einstein had
lived and we found his house at one 12
Mercer.
It was undergoing some sort
of construction so it was
sort of cordoned off by
yellow tape, like a murder scene,
but we just stood there in awe,
trespassing on Einstein's
lawn to bogus press badges,
still hanging around our necks.
And it struck me then that this little
private hobby that I shared with my dad
was maybe going to be something bigger.
And it also dawned on me that I was not
ready to give up this journalism front
because it was like just
too good to be true.
Like all you need is this press badge
and suddenly you can learn physics
directly from the physicists.
I figured the Manhattan magazine Scam
wouldn't work for long because someone was
bound to look it up and
see that it didn't exist.
But I figured I would use it one more
time. So when I got back to New York,
I called an editor at scientific American.
Again,
I lied and said it was journalists with
Manhattan magazine and that I had been
to this conference and I wanted to cover,
um,
or you know, write an article
about physics for their magazine.
And miraculously he agreed.
So my article comes out in scientific
American and suddenly my fake journalism
career has just morphed into
a real journalism career.
And I was able to use that to sort of
worm my way into more situations where it
didn't belong. So I'm sure you can
see like Stephen Hawking there,
front and center,
and then there inexplicably is me.
It was the perfect scam.
And at this particular conference,
I ended up meeting an editor
from New Scientist magazine.
We struck up a conversation
and I mentioned that I wrote
for scientific American.
I didn't mention it was only once and it
was the only article I've ever done. Um,
and he suggested maybe I should
write for new scientists.
And so I started writing articles
for New Scientist. And then, um,
when I turned 25,
New Scientist asked me to be an editor
there landing me the ultimate permanent
press that okay.
So once I was an editor at
like a major science magazine,
I had access to everything that my
father and I needed to learn physics and
start to figure out the origin of the
universe, which is the whole point.
Um, and I was learning so much
trying to come to grips with this,
something that's supposedly a rose
from nothing 14 billion years ago.
And if you try to learn all the
fundamental physics from scratch,
not only is it a lot to learn,
but it can seem like a lot of
sort of crazy unrelated facts.
But early on I had an epiphany that
made it infinitely easier to connect the
dots and to see the big picture.
And so I think if you want to know
one thing about fundamental physics,
this is the one thing to
know something is only real.
If it's invariant.
And I'll explain what that means.
Something is only real if it remains
unchanged in every reference frame.
If it changes or disappears
from some perspective,
then it's not ultimately real.
And actually,
even though this is very deep idea,
it's something that we all
sort of know intuitively.
Like if you were sitting in your lobby
and out of the corner of your eye,
you saw like an elephant walk by,
like even for Google,
that would be pretty unusual.
And you might find yourself wondering,
is that elephant real or am I
having some kind of breakdown?
And instinctively,
you know,
there are two strategies
that you can use to find out.
So the first would be to get up,
walk over to the elephant and just sort
of walk in a circle around it from every
angle suspiciously because you know
that if at some angle it just vanishes.
Then it was something more like
a mirage and less like a mammal.
And the other strategy you can use is
to just turn to the Googler next to you
and say,
do you see that elephant to?
And if she says no or just
stares at you blankly,
then you know that you should
probably go see a neurologist.
And why do you know that?
Because you know that something is only
real if it remains invariant and every
reference frame.
Okay?
So just because something's
not ultimately real,
it doesn't mean it has to
be a hallucination, right?
Like take a rainbow is a rainbow real,
not really,
right? I mean it's not subjective.
It's not a hallucination. Um,
but it's also not like a physical
object hanging in the sky.
You can't go touch it because it's a
product of your reference frame, right?
You see a rainbow when you're standing
in just the right spot and the sun
streaming in from behind you and the
lights being refracted by the moisture in
the air. And if you ask the guy next
to you, do you see that rainbow too?
He'll probably say yes. But if you run
the test of walking around in a circle,
you will eventually see it disappear
because it's not invariant.
It's not ultimately real.
It's not a fundamental
ingredient of ultimate reality.
And so if you want to find the
fundamental ingredients, ultimate reality,
the something that arose from nothing,
you have to find what's invariant.
So if there's one thing that you
remember about physics, let it be that
it was Einstein who first recognized
this link between invariance and reality.
And I would actually argue that this was
Einstein's single greatest contribution
to physics, which I realize is a very bold
statement. And he did a lot of things,
special relativity,
general activity.
It's not even what he won
the Nobel prize for her.
You want it for the photo electric effect,
which is just so bad ass
if you think about it,
because it's like the thing he wanted to
know about prize for barely cracked the
list of the best things we ever did.
But the best thing he ever did was to
eliminate this link between invariance in
reality because it's set the future
trajectory of modern physics and motion.
And it changed physics from being a set
of rules and numbers that describe how
levers and pulleys work to being a way to
glimpse the reality behind appearances.
And there's a good reason that no one
before Einstein thought of this link
between invariants and reality.
And it's that before Einstein,
everyone shared the same reference frame.
So in a Newtonian universe,
the speed of light is instantaneous,
which means everyone sees the same thing.
So everything's in variant.
And in Einstein's universe,
this is no longer true.
So Einstein realized that in order for
every observer to see the same laws of
physics, um, every observer has to
measure the speed of light to be the same.
And so it doesn't matter if you're
running a million miles an hour or you're
standing still,
as you measure a beam of light,
that beam of light is going to be
moving in 186,000 miles per second.
And what's important about that
number is that it's finite.
Light does not travel
instantaneously. It takes time, right?
Light from the sun takes
eight minutes to reach us.
Light from distant galaxies takes
millions or even billions of years.
And so looking out into the universe
as a way of looking back in time.
But the point is you can't see everything.
The universe that you can see is bounded
by the fact that light has only had 14
billion years to reach you.
And so beyond that,
the universe for you is dark.
Now the boundary that marks the
very edge of what you can see,
it's called your horizon
and it's uniquely yours.
You are sitting at the center of a sphere
that encompasses your one of a kind
universe and the person next to you is
sitting at the center of a different
sphere. Now, they mostly
overlap, but not entirely.
And so Einstein realized that in a
universe with a finite speed of light,
every observer occupies
a unique reference frame.
So you can no longer just describe the
universe without first specifying from
WHO's frame you're describing it.
Because things might look very
different from one frame to another.
And if things look very different
from one frame to another,
this introduces a
fundamentally new problem.
How do you know which things are real?
And Einstein figured out the solution.
Something is real if it's in variant,
in every reference frame.
So it was this way of thinking that
led Einstein to his famous discovery,
right? By analyzing how things
look from different frames,
he was able to see that space and time,
which everyone had always assumed were
the same for every observer are in fact
not the same for every observer.
They look different from one reference
frame to another. So what I see as space,
you might experience
this time and vice versa.
And so space and time are not invariant.
They are relative to your reference frame.
That's what relativity is.
But he found that there is something
that remains in variant and that is this
combination of space and time,
this unified four dimensional space time.
So we might disagree on
measurements of space or have time,
but everyone will always agree on
measurements of this combined spacetime.
Okay?
So space and time are not real spacetime
Israel and everyone always focuses on
the first part because it's like really
mindblowing. Space and time aren't real.
But I'm site actually cared more about
the second part because he knew that the
key to finding ultimate reality
is to find the invariant.
And actually later in life he said that
he regretted calling it the theory of
relativity and wished that instead he
had called it the theory of invariance.
So once we knew all of this,
my father and I now had like a
concrete plan, like the question,
what is ultimately real? You know, what
is the something that arose from nothing?
It was no longer this sort of
vague philosophical question.
It was a rigorous physics question.
You know, what is invariant?
And so we were out to breakfast at a
pancake house and we wrote a list of
possible ingredients of
ultimate reality on a Napkin.
So things like spacetime
dimensionality, particles, strings,
et cetera. Um, this image,
by the way, is a recreation.
The original Napkin was eventually lost,
her possibly sneezed in,
but we made this list and then I used
my journalism career to investigate each
one. And I want to tell you about
two of the items on the Napkin.
So the first one is particles.
Particles seem pretty fundamental,
right?
If you ask what is all the stuff in
the universe made of particles is the
obvious answer or what I thought until I
encountered the work of Stephen Hawking.
So I have to confess something. When I
was first learning all of this stuff,
I had the suspicion that
Stephen Hawking was overrated.
Like I just wasn't convinced that
his contribution to physics could be
proportionate to his same because there's
just something about a guy that speaks
in a computer voice that
sort of automatically sounds
like a genius. You know,
like he automatically sounds like he
knows something no one else could possibly
know.
But as I studied his work,
I learned that he had done this remarkable
calculation in the 1970s actually he
was annoyed at another physicist.
And so he was doing this calculation in
order to show that this other guy was
wrong. And the calculation
proved three things first.
That revenge is an excellent
fuel for genius. Second,
that I was an idiot because if anything,
hawking is underrated.
His physics was brilliant and the only
thing that's disproportionate is the fact
that everyone knows
who Stephen Hawking is.
But if you ask them what did he
actually do that was so important,
hardly anyone knows.
But now you guys will know because
I'll tell you the third thing,
his calculation prove that
particles are not ultimately real.
And here's why.
So thanks to quantum mechanics.
Empty space is not really empty.
The uncertainty principle,
it tells us there's a tradeoff
between time and energy,
which means that on
incredibly short timescales,
fraction of a fraction of a fraction
of a second large amounts of energy can
bubble up out of empty space.
And this energy takes the form of pairs
of particles and antiparticles that
emerged from empty space and then meat
and annihilate and in the blink of an eye
disappear. And this is happening
all the time, all around us,
these particles and
antiparticles emerging meeting,
annihilating and disappearing.
But it happens so quickly that we just
refer to them as virtual particles.
But when hockey was
doing this calculation,
he realized that something different
happens when you have a horizon.
And so as you already know,
horizon marks the an edge beyond which
like can't reach an observer, right?
So we talked about the horizon that
surrounds your unique universe and there's
an analogous kind of horizon.
It's actually mathematically equivalent
kind of horizon that surrounds a black
hole.
So in this case,
the horizon marks the edge beyond which
light can't escape gravity's clutches in
order to reach an observer on the outside.
So if you're standing
outside the black hole,
the horizon marks the
edge of what you can see.
So hawking realized that if these
pairs of particle virtual particles and
antiparticles are bubbling up out of
empty space in the vicinity of a horizon,
something sort of amazing,
it can happen.
The horizon can separate the pairs so
that where one particle sort of is just
outside the horizon,
it's antiparticle partner can be just
inside the black hole and now they can no
longer annihilate.
And so instead of disappearing
and they just stick around,
these virtual particles
are not so virtual anymore.
They're actually totally normal particles
that are exactly the same as the
particles that make up
anything in this room.
You could collect them until
them and build a chair.
But there would be something really
weird about that chair because it would,
oh its existence to the horizon,
but the horizon's not a real thing.
The horizon's not like a brick wall that's
floating in space or horizons like a
rainbow.
It's a product of a reference Rayme
namely the reference frame of an observer
who is lucky enough to remain
outside the black hole.
And textbooks tend to call the
observer outside the black hole. Bob,
I like to call them safe.
There's another kind of
observer who's not so lucky.
I'm an observer who's in inertial motion.
Freefall can't escape gravity's clutches
and fall straight through the rise in
and into the black hole.
And I like to call him screwed.
So from safety point of view,
these
once virtual particles that can no
longer annihilate with their partners are
streaming out from the horizon as
if the black hole is radiating.
That's why we call it hawking radiation.
But for screwed,
there is no horizon.
He's just fall straight through and
there's no edge of what he can see.
So for screwed these virtual particles
just continue to annihilate and disappear
like always.
And so where safe sees this stream of
hot particles screw just ordinary empty
space.
So you see what's happening here.
The particles are not invariant
and that's what hawking discovered.
That's so important.
Particles are not ultimately real.
They're a product of your reference frame,
not only in the vicinity of a black hole
but everywhere because every one of us
has surrounded by horizon.
So my father and I crossed particles
off the list on the Napkin.
Now Hawking's discovery has driven and
continues to drive theoretical physics
forward for the last four
decades because it's rife with,
and there's nothing that a
physicist loves more than a paradox.
And I'll give you an example.
So let's take our elephant from the
lobby and throw him into a black hole.
All right,
there he goes.
So safe is watching this from afar.
And so we can ask in safes reference
frame, what does this look like?
And Fair warning,
it's not pretty.
So from safe's point of view,
the elephant is going to fall towards
the black hole and then encounter this
stream of hot hawking radiation and she's
going to be burned to a crisp before
he ever crosses the horizon in his Astros
will just sort of emanate back into
the universe. Okay, so
that's gruesome in terrible,
but we can also look at
screwed point of view, right?
Because screwed is just falling straight
through alongside the elephant and for
screwed.
There is no horizon.
So there are no hot particles to harm
any animals and so for screwed the
elephant,
it's just in ordinary empty space and he
can live out the rest of his life until
he eventually reaches the
center of the black hole.
So there's a problem.
Okay.
The Laws of physics require that
both of these stories be true.
If either one of them were not true,
you'd violate a law of physics.
And so the elephant has to be both dead
in a pile of ashes outside the black
hole and alive and well
inside the black hole.
That alone is just weird.
But the problem comes in because
there's another law of physics.
It's equally as fundamental as the others
that says you can't have two copies of
the same elephant.
So both stories have to be true
and both stories can't be true.
That's the paradox.
And it was a physicist named Lenny
Suskind who solved this paradox.
He said, as long as you stick to
one observers reference frame,
as long as you talk about what safe sees
or what screwed sees all the laws of
physics remained intact.
It's only when you try to talk about
their points of view simultaneously that
you see these two illegal
copies of the elephant.
So it's this picture. That's
the problem. Einstein had said,
you know,
if you describe the university,
you have to first specify
your reference frame.
And the fact is this isn't unphysical
reference frame. It's impossible.
There's no one who can see inside and
outside of horizon simultaneously.
That's the idea of a horizon.
And so as long as we just stick
to physical reference frames,
what an observer could actually see that
we never see two copies of the elephant
and all the laws of physics remain
intact. So the problem is solved, but
there's still something very unsettling
about that because we would like to
think that there's some actual answer
to the question. Where is the elephant?
Right?
Is the elephant dead outside the black
hole or is it alive inside a black hole?
We like to think that
there's some real answer.
And what this is telling us is that
there's not so Suskin realized that the
location of the elephant in
spacetime is not invariant.
So spacetime,
this unified four dimensional space time
that was left in variant by Einstein's
theory of, and Marion's turns
out not to be in very after all.
And so my dad and I had to
cross spacetime off the list.
So we continued our search for
these ever elusive in variants,
these fundamental ingredients
of ultimate reality.
I was running around the world having
fascinating conversations with these
brilliant physicist and usually making
a total fool of myself in the process.
And often my dad was there with
me and when he couldn't be,
I would report back to him and detail
all of my crazy adventures and everything
I had learned.
But looking back on this 17 year journey,
here's what I realize now, if
I, if it weren't for my father,
I would have never done any of this.
Like even if I had somehow become
interested in physics on my own,
I would have never crashed a
conference posing as a journalist.
I would have never turned one little lie
into an entire career because without
my dad there at my side or on
the other end of the phone,
it wouldn't have been fun and
it wouldn't have meant anything.
And that's the thing about invariance.
It doesn't just make objects real.
It makes our lives real. And I really
think that's why we need other people.
We need them because they bear
witness to our lives. And in doing so,
they anchor us to the world.
The anchor us to a reality that can
be seen from every angle when you walk
around it.
I needed my dad because that's second
reference frame gave my life a sense of
invariance and created between us a shared
reality so that every time I learned
something deep and wondrous about the
universe, I could turn to my dad and say,
do you see that too? And he could
smile back at me and say, yes,
but just as we were creating
this shared reality,
we were also chipping away at it piece
by piece as we crossed item after item
off the Napkin,
slowly undermining the very
notion of a shared reality.
Because once you know this one thing about
physics that what's real is what's in
variant.
The entire trajectory of physics
sort of snaps into focus.
The whole history of physics from Einstein
to exactly what's going on right now
has been a steady and relentless
progression of invariant
after invariant giving
way to observe her
dependence and illusion.
And so the list of fundamental ingredients
of reality is getting shorter and
shorter and shorter.
And so we can ask like,
where does this trajectory end? Does
it end with one fundamental ingredient,
one in variant,
one thing that everything else is made of?
Well that used to be the hope.
I mean a lot of people thought that
that was sort of the idea of of string
theory, right? That all
these different things,
all this variety we see in the world,
it's actually all just meet
up of this one ingredient,
these little vibrating strings.
But the most exciting and interesting
and challenging thing that's happened in
string theory in recent years is that
it's turned out the strings are not in
variant.
And so this is,
this are starting to think that maybe
there's not one fundamental ingredient.
And so, so where does the
trajectory end? Does it end it?
Nothing. Because here's the
interesting thing about nothing.
If you think about it, not in terms of
what it isn't, but in terms of what it is,
an infinite unbounded homogeneous state
is by definition in variant in every
possible reference frame.
So my dad had started with the sort of
existential question of how do you get
something from nothing?
And
now everything we were
learning was presenting us
with the very real possibility
that that something might not be made.
Anything that something might be nothing.
And
on the one hand that's really good news
because that actually offers a possible
solution to this sort of
ancient existential riddle.
But on the other hand,
it's kind of a bummer when you've just
spent 17 years trying to create a shared
reality with your father only to
learn that there maybe no such thing.
You know,
physics taught me that I have my reference
frame and my dad has his reference
frame and they mostly
overlap but not entirely,
which I think is just another way
to say that over the past 17 years,
physics has taught me
what it means to grow up,
but still I'm comforted to know that
there is a reference frame in which we are
together side by side,
my dad and me.
And that's the reference frame that
sits between the covers of my book.
So thank you very much.
Okay,
I can take questions.
Anyone has,
what's a good suggestion for getting our
daughter's involved in math and science?
Um, you have a chance to speak with a
lot of people who've made this be their
profession and, uh, from
their experience and yours,
what do you think is a good first step?
So I think it depends
on like personality a lot.
So for me,
I was sort of this rebellious kid and I
think if physics had been presented to
me in any normal way, like as like
something you have to study in school,
I just don't think it would've
ever like captured my imagination.
I think it was the fact
that my dad presented it as
this like secret thing that
we were going to do and
it was this mission,
we're going to figure out
the origin of the universe.
And it felt like by doing physics
that was rebelling in some way.
And so, which actually, I mean
I've thought about this a lot.
I think physics is a very inherently
rebellious subject because it requires you
to sort of question everything
we think we know about reality.
And if you look at sort of the
greatest physicists of all time,
they tend to be very
rebellious characters.
So I think it's sort of a shame because
a lot of times the people who are sort
of encouraged to go into science and
math tend to be like this sort of very
studious people who sort
of like go by the book.
And that's not always going to be,
I mean you need that,
but that's not always going to be
like the most creative thinkers.
And I think sometimes we weed out
creative thinkers who could've really
contributed to physics by not
appealing to that type of kid.
Um,
but you know,
I realize not everyone's going to go on
a secret mission for 17 years to figure
out the nature of the universe.
Um, so I don't know. I mean,
I really think it's like the physics
that's taught in school cool.
Like you don't get to the really good
stuff until you've already sort of
committed,
right?
So like you do Newtonian physics in high
school and then it's not until like if
you did physics in college,
like you'll start to get into relativity
and quantum mechanics and that's where
it gets really cool.
But I think you can actually present
those topics to kids without needing a
crazy amount of math that they don't have.
And so I think if there was a way
to present the cooler parts physics,
a really exciting sort of mind blowing
stuff earlier on so that they would see
that, okay, I have to get
through all this other stuff,
but it's going to be really
good. I feel like, you know,
people would be more into it.
Right?
So I'm actually like about 50%
through your book right now. Um,
and I have this problem when reading like
the sort of theoretical physics books,
which is at, you know, I usually
follow through, you know,
special relativity and general relativity.
But once I get to sections about,
you know, um, like supersymmetry
and string theory and
things like that, you know,
like I just stopped understanding.
And um,
you actually talk a little bit about
this in your book that, you know,
part of the problem here is that these
aren't actually like accurate because
really they're just describing
these mathematical equations, right?
Is it impossible to understand this
stuff without understanding like the math
involved or is this,
is it something that you encountered
when you were learning this at some point
did you just like say
like, wow, like, you know,
I didn't take physics but now
I have to like learn, you know,
differential equations just to, you
know, even understand this at all.
Right. It's a really good question. Um,
and I've sort of struggled
with this because there
definitely were times where I
was like, oh my God, like I'm reading
through these papers and I'm like,
if I knew this math,
this would be a lot easier.
And I think it's true what
you were referring to.
Like this idea that physics is
expressed in mathematics, right?
And then if you try to
translate that into English,
there's not a one to one correlation
between English and math.
And so something is inevitably
lost in the translation. Um,
and,
and science writers tend
to rely a lot on metaphors.
And so now you're almost like an another
level where you're like losing a little
bit something. Yeah. It might make
it easier to sort of understand,
but on the other hand you're
like losing more of the nuance.
And so you might say you can't really
understand it unless you understand the
math.
But on the other hand,
you know like the joke that
like the meaning of life,
the universe and everything is
42 like the reason that's funny,
like why is 42 not a satisfying answer?
Because you want like an
answer in English, right?
Like you want like a number wouldn't be
the answer because we want to know what
it means.
And so the math doesn't tell
you what anything means.
And so even though you lose
something in the translation,
you gain a sense of meaning.
And
a lot of physics is really based on
principles and having these foundational
principles and then deriving
the math from that. You know,
that's how Einstein worked.
And so you can understand all the
principles without understanding like the
particular solutions of equations.
And so I think you actually can have a
complete big picture understanding even
if you can't sit down and
actually do a particular problem.
Yeah.
My understanding of string theory, by the
way, I really enjoy your New York talk.
Thank you. My understanding of string
theory is a little bit, uh, outdated. Um,
why are strings, uh, not in variant?
Yeah, great question. Um, so
there was a period of time where everyone
was hoping that was the case and then
this is realized they had five different
versions of string theory that we're
all completely consistent. And so this
was sort of an embarrassment of riches.
Like you don't want five
dairies have everything,
you want one theory of everything.
And so this was sort of a crisis and Ed
Witten came along and he realized that
actually these five string theories,
even though they look very different,
are all mathematically equivalent.
There's transformations that you
can make to go from one to another.
And that's really unexpected because
you have like a theory with strings
vibrating in 10 dimensions and then you
have a theory of like these membranes
and 11 dimensions and then you have
particles and you have like radically
different space,
time geometries and,
and things that you would look to us like
drastically different physical worlds.
And they're actually all
descriptions of the same thing.
And so that was,
you know,
people refer to that as the
second superstring revolution.
And that was sort of considered this
amazing step because it's like, oh,
we don't really have five days.
We have one theory and now we'll
call it m theory. And that's great.
But what m theory is telling you is that
things like dimensionality and strings
are not invariant because what looked
like strings in one point of view,
one of these series look like particles
in another and they look at the memories
and another and what looks
like 10 dimensions and one
is 11 dimensions and other.
And there's no way to say that. Like it's
not like one's right and one's wrong.
It's just that there are two different
ways of looking at the exact same thing.
And so now m theory basically undermined
the idea that you can have an invariant
fundamental ingredient.
I was just snooping on your bookshelf.
So,
I know you've run into a couple of these,
and I'm,
I'm not going to remember the guys names,
but there are a couple of people who,
um, look at the, the,
the sort of the evolving
contradictions, uh, and,
and
if you wind up proving that
nothing is real, you know,
like if all of our particles,
the makeup us in this room
right now or originated, uh,
as hawking radiation and, and, you know,
so there's some frame of reference from
which absolutely nothing is real, that,
uh,
that you,
you sort of need to find another
kind of answer to things that,
what you've, you've the, I, I think
of that, uh, there's sort of like
a girly girl, listen, you know, notion of,
of completeness and being able to
prove the system is completed then the,
that may be, so you've got
the guy who thinks, uh,
the entire universe is
a cellular automata.
And then there's also the, uh, the,
the sort of thought experiment thing
that suggests that maybe the entire
universe is a simulation and
somebody else's universe. Uh,
uh,
I don't know.
I just wondered what you thought
about those kinds of notions.
Yeah, so they're all
really interesting. Um,
I think the same problems sort
of plague all of those ideas.
And the simulation question is really
interesting and it's actually directly
related to Godel
incompleteness theorem because
the sort of main conceptual difficulty
in talking about the universe as a whole,
especially when you have to apply like
quantum mechanics to the university as a
whole is the fact that
unlike anything else that we know of,
the universe only has an inside.
It doesn't have an outside,
it's like a one sided coin.
And so you can't have an
observer outside the universe.
So the universe is this like set
that contains itself, you know,
like you get into these
weird paradoxes and the,
there's no way for an observer to describe
the universe without it being self
referential in some sense because
the observers part of the universe.
And so with the simulation question,
you're saying, you know, what, if this
whole universe is actually, you know,
a simulation embedded on a
computer and some higher reality,
well,
for one thing, I don't know
that it would matter that much.
Like they would still be some fundamental
laws of physics that I really believe
you would be able to figure out. Um, but
there's also like,
in order to assess the reality of reality,
you have to step outside of it, right? So
like to know that you were a simulation,
you'd have to be outside the simulation
and then how do you know that that's not
a simulation? You'd have to be
outside of that. And so it's again,
this question of what is
your reference frame like,
because by definition you
can't be outside reality.
And so there is no reference frame from
which you can determine the reality of
reality. And so I don't know if
that totally answers your question,
but I think,
I think all of these issues that
you're raising are very related. Um,
and you know, Stephen Wolfram's
theory that you were referring to.
Um,
it was really interesting.
I don't really know it well enough to
comment that intelligibly but I mean it's,
it's going to be subject to the same
issues that we're talking here but because
it's another way of doing things but
it still has to like replicate all of
physics as we know it. And so it's
going to run into these same questions.
Emails.
That's true.
Makes Sense. Because this stuff's
amazing but also makes my head spin.
But what is, you said there was a
trajectory and things are, you know,
what is in variance becoming smaller
and smaller and it may be nothing,
but what is the end game for?
Obviously there's an end game for people
that study this and are amazed by and
everything else. But for someone who
doesn't have this understanding, your,
and when, if there is an end game
where it does become figured out,
does it have an effect on those?
Like what,
what effect could it have on
people outside of just in theory?
Um,
I mean I think,
I don't think it's going
like have technological
applications. I mean, I don't,
you never know. Right? You never know.
You can ever see these things coming.
But I think this is really just about
answering sort of deep existential
questions that humans have been asking
for as long as there have been humans.
Right. I mean the question
of like, what is real?
What am I, how am I here? What
am I seeing? I mean it's just,
I think it's just things that
we deeply want to know. And,
and it's funny because on the one hand
it seems like incredibly abstract,
especially if you're talking about what
you have 14 billion years ago and the
origin of the universe or the cosmos,
which is so huge and quantum mechanics,
which is the scale is so tiny and you
sort of can't like place herself in these
things. But I always have these
moments where like, cause I get,
you know,
I start thinking about this stuff and
it kind of start taking it for granted a
little bit. And then like all of a sudden
I'll have this moment where I'm like,
oh my God. Like I'm talking about like
literally like this isn't real. You know,
like I'll have like I'm talking about the
stuff right here and me and all of us.
And so it's not that abstract.
It's just like you can't really live
your life thinking about it every minute
like that or else you're going
to have a problem. But yeah.
So I think it's just sort of,
I mean I think anytime you have a better
understanding of the way that nature
works,
it's going to have some positive
effect or maybe not positive.
It's going to have some effect. It's going
to be useful in some way. Um, but yeah,
when you get to this level, like
will it be practical? Probably not,
sorry for being a stick in
the mud, but, uh, if they're,
if strings aren't invariant is,
are there any invariance in theory,
there are, not that anyone knows him. Um,
and it's really interesting because
when I've talked to string theorists
and I'll say like, like you, you'll hear
a string theorists will say things like,
we don't really know what the theory
is. Like, we have all these equations,
we have the theory,
but we don't know what it's a theory of.
And what they mean by that is like,
you know,
like quantum field theory is
a theory of quantum fields.
String theory was a theory,
strengths m theory,
they don't know like
they have the steering,
they don't know what it's describing
and there's no basic ontology there and
they're well aware of that.
And it's like
they see it as either something will
emerge and there will be something that is
describing that we just don't realize yet.
I happen to think it's
actually more useful if, if
there's not an ontology there,
because now you can answer this question
of how you get something from nothing.
But I mean, it's really
fascinating like m theory, like,
you know, if you read physics books,
like everything you read will say,
nobody knows what the m stands for.
Like maybe it stands for
mystery or mother magic or,
um, you know, I think there was
a Nobel prize winner who said,
I think it stands,
it's the upside down w for Whitten.
And people had all these
theories about like,
like even you read Stephen Hawking's book,
it's like,
no one knows what the m stands for. And
I'm kind of like, how can no one, no,
like Edwin coined it and he's still alive.
Like, why doesn't someone just ask him?
And so I went and I asked
him and he was like,
it stands for membrane. Like I,
you know, originally said like, oh,
it could be mother mystery, whatever.
But I was kidding. You know?
And nobody really got the joke.
But,
so the m stands for membrane,
but membranes are not invariant
and that theory. And so,
yeah.
So there's a deeper point to the like, no
one knows what I'm stands for, which is,
even though like,
literally it stands for membrane.
I think part of what that means is like
they don't know what it's a theory of.
It's just never really happened. I mean,
it's like a weird way of doing physics,
but fascinating.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you guys so much for coming.
[inaudible].